all right so it's been mostly you know
kind of a serious downer of a show today
in some sense i want to go through a
couple things that are a little bit
lighter although not particularly less
disturbing i guess depending on your
perspective about the types of people
that
are or have been in prominent positions
of power
you may remember donald trump's former
press secretary
kaylee mcinanni she
was one of trump's many press
secretaries and one of the things that
happened on the first
day that she addressed or answered
questions in the press briefing room was
that
she said she was never going to lie to
the press corps she was asked
will you tell us today you will not lie
to us
and she said no i will not and of course
almost exclusively she lied for donald
trump
day after day after day she recently
spoke at a
turning point usa event it was a really
strange
event but the highlight was her saying
she never did lie
as the white house press secretary and
it was because of her faith
and because of god that she didn't lie
you this you have to see
take a look and then there was the
question will you ever lie to us
and i said without hesitation no and i
never did
she certainly didn't hesitate but she
did lie
women of faith as a mother of baby blake
as a person who meticulously prepared
at some of the world's hardest
institutions i never lied
i sourced my information nobody who went
to harvard ever lies right i mean that
that's no no religious person or
harvard graduate would ever tell an
untruth information
but that will never stop the press from
calling you a liar
also lying will make it so that people
call you a liar
which is why my dad said kayla you've
got to come up with a motto for your
press shop and i did and our motto was
this
offense only because
[Music]
wow because i knew what we were up
against
republicans always get the bad headlines
always get the false stories always get
the
lies if i can use that word told by the
press there is one standard for
democrats
and another for republicans yeah so okay
so basically she
she wants us to believe she never told a
lie at all
uh while she was donald trump's white
house press secretary i actually it's
it's almost everything is backwards i
have a hard time
remembering a more dishonest
press secretary i i don't know who it
would be if you said who was a more
dishonest press secretary than kaylee
mcinanni
i don't know that i can think of one
here is kaylee just as a few examples
telling us
covid affects virtually
nobody remember this gem follow up last
night the president
said at one of his rallies about the
virus
i think he was talking about younger
americans he said it affects virtually
nobody
by the way open your schools everybody
open your schools
but he said to bob woodward it's not
just old
it's not just older people it's young
people too
at 200 000 deaths shouldn't the
president be telling people the truth
about this virus at his rallies the
president is telling people the truth
and you're right jim that he was talking
about
saying that it affects virtually nobody
and that it doesn't affect young people
he's not telling the truth those are
like but you're again taking the
president out of context i have his full
quote here
and you're right that he was referring
to young people he said this
i'm not taking it out of context so i
said he was talking about younger people
quoting someone and explaining what the
context
was is not taking someone out of context
that's true
you are taking it out of context because
you're making an assertion that he's not
giving critical information when in fact
he is
and i will underscore exactly what he
said okay so complete
and total liar all the time here's
another one
where kaylee says trump never downplayed
the virus
even though trump told bob woodward i
publicly downplayed the virus take a
look
because i don't want to create a panic
the president by his own admission
in private on the record acknowledged
the depth of this crisis
and yet told the american people
something very different right how is
that at its core
not an abject betrayal of the public
trust the president has always been
clear-eyed with the american people he
was always clear-eyed about the lives we
could lose yeah
like when he said the lives we could
lose are we have 15 cases which will
soon be zero he was
really clear with the american people
about the hell that was coming
again from this podium he acknowledged
that this was serious back in march that
a hundred thousand two hundred thousand
lives could be lost
now remember back that's a lie in march
he was saying
and i don't even know if it was march
even by april he was still only saying
we might lose
50 000 people i mean it was all just lie
after lie
after lie uh here she is saying trump is
the most
informed person on the planet about
threats to the united states and the
american people
the president does read and he also
consumes intelligence
verbally this president i'll tell you is
the most informed person on planet earth
when it comes to the threats that we
face
you have ambassador o'brien who sees him
in person twice a day
who sometimes takes the upwards of half
a dozen calls
with this president he's constantly
being informed and briefed on
intelligence matters
um but i'm not going to allow the new
york times to dictate
when we give top secret information and
don't give time there is no more
informed person
my friends than donald trump and then
lastly
another lie from kaylee mcinanny which
was her participation in the lies
about the 2020 election she was trotted
out there i don't remember if it was in
her capacity i think this was her
capacity as an advisor to trump
um you know she had multiple different
roles remember this one
we want to protect the franchise of the
american people
we want an honest accurate lawful
count we want maximum sunlight we want
maximum transparency we want
every legal vote to be counted and we
want every
illegal vote i just think we have to be
very clear that she's charging uh
this by the way when this was too
dishonest even for fox news this is a
fox host cutting in and saying this is
crazy
welcoming fraud and welcoming illegal
voting unless she has more details to
back that up
i can't in good countenance continue
showing you this i want to make sure
that
yeah when even fox news says i can't
show you this guys this is even making
fox news blush so kaylee mcinanny now
taking credit for never having lied
and it is a liar lying
about their lying that's quite frankly
all it is
and it shouldn't surprise us one of our
sponsors today is
nebia the creator of the world's most
innovative
shower head it uses only about half
the water that other shower heads do
saving you money helping the environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about
half as much water nebia also offers a
number of shower accessories like
shelves and curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just 199
and you'll get 10 percent off
all nebia products when you go to
nebia.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link is right underneath this video